[Music]
and power of the internet news submitted
by como estas JK Oh muy bien muy bien
Norman's Greta's a viral photo of a
frost-covered 8 year old boy has sparked
almost $16,000 in donations from the
internet that's a lot of money what is
going on you could buy a heater for like
25 bucks just to let you know just to
put it out there than cheaper than that
yeah
is it like medical bills because he's
got frost bites and he needs to like
something here's a condition where he
freezes
holy [ __ ] seems like a cartoon he's
starting Super Saiyan yeah the kids are
laughing at him yes so this is these are
the photos that went viral on his hands
frostbitten yes oh my god you know like
a Christmas tree with the flood yeah
legit thought that was just his
hairstyle frosted tips that's a
different meaning of this what he looks
like normally so cheeks are still
Mongolia some type in China it was like
a friend of Malaysia so funny dad yeah
so that photo went viral and it was
discovered later on that he has to
travel about three miles on foot to get
to his school and the day that this
photo was taken with the first day of
their exams and so like he obviously
just didn't want to miss that day and my
mom's been stealing this full stories
she tells me about how she had to go to
school she told me that she had to ride
a bike five miles to school and she only
had one pedal I don't like [ __ ] but I
still in this full story I was just huge
another know I should squeeze my mom
thighs I'm like you're a lying sack of
[ __ ] they're the same yes it was about
15 degrees Fahrenheit or negative 9
degrees Celsius damn we been in that
weather yeah Minnesota damn walking
around with no gloves yeah hospitai why
did he buy some North Face stuff or take
a t-shirt or effing lady
that's why once this went viral on the
internet a lot of people just started
giving donations even donated a lot of
like coats and gloves and stuff where
was this located in China oh yeah
three miles just to go to school in
northeastern yuan province if you guys
really want to know exactly where so
this is when they were getting like
coats and gloves from people donating it
to them that's awesome and so luckily
thanks to the internet you know very
thirty could've died yeah you could've
died yeah that's crazy man these kids
are so determined the [ __ ] that other
people go through in other countries and
just the shirt just toughness and what
they have to deal with it's so different
so it's just to go to school yeah
cuz I'm like I'm trying to go to school
yeah we're doing is backwards weird yeah
every weekend not to go yeah you know
what I mean and they're just like
desperate for an education so they can
like who's given to us I'd rather be
sick and stay home and this was I
[ __ ] I'm gonna risk my life to go to
school that's why that's why I mister
that's why communism socialism that
stuff doesn't work all the way because
like when things are just giving out
freely like that's what you don't want
to go cuz like before you only you could
only get an education if you were
wealthy you know like you were the elite
then you could be educated now it's
public education no one wants to [ __ ]
go it's super entitled yeah I mean I was
starting from elementary I was like why
do I gotta go I don't want to go right
because you didn't have to earn it right
it wasn't something that people waved in
front of you is that you can have this
you know maybe that's what we should do
you're not going to be able to read okay
yeah so now people are saying like this
is awesome for them and that's cool but
you guys also have to remember there's
many other schools out and like all over
the world where they don't have the the
same luck as to get viral and to get
help
there's so many frosty hairs all over
the world the Dragon Ball Z character
what does that mean like go out and look
for it or what pretty much I just
remember like there's more schools that
are like that that's what a lot of yours
I saw this one photos it was pretty
crazy it was a bunch of little Russian
boys and girls on like a tree just like
on a tree like a branch branch yeah just
sitting there because the description
was a lot of these kids during the
winter their parents just drink and
abuse them and beat their asses so they
all come outside in the freezing cold
and just sit on that tree branch so they
don't get abused by their parents oh my
god and I was like that is some crazy
[ __ ] so they're all just huddled
together and in sitting on the tree
branch and I'm like that's where they
grew up to be all cold-hearted that's
why they're so tough I'm like I thought
I had it by but damn dude I was always
welcome back in the house fear of
getting your ass beat was so it is
pretty scary
yes I [ __ ] hated that feeling they
just waiting for doom to come on your
ass cheeks but can you imagine how how
much crazier their life was if they have
to run out and just be in the cold in
the freezing snow dude I could never
live in Russia just like I would be
angry to I'd want to beat my kids too
like it's so cold all the time and like
that's how you warm up by [ __ ]
stalking your kids in the face they
drink and feed their kids because I know
they got secretly in Sturgeon all day so
but I'm just not sure that's very cool
and cold makes me angry
so heat makes me angry really angry at
me you only go into Hawaii but that's
different though
cuz that's heat with beautiful air ocean
and trees and people are nice there oh
are you are you talking about like
desert heat or are you talking about I
don't mind being in the tropics and
being hot because that's just how it is
you know I mean we're over here and it's
like a dry hundred and ten degrees mmm
it's really dry here and if it was like
a little bit more humid it would be
nicer well we got the beach here cuz car
the beach even like dry it's like it
just feels dry sure it's not it's not
like humid like Hawaii I love the cold
when when I'm super active cuz the air
just tastes sweet like it's a cold glass
of water I only like the cold one I'm
completely covered and I know it's cold
because I see everyone else is called
but like me I'm just like have you ever
ran in the cold no ready as hell and
it's cooling you down but you're hot as
hell I don't like it cuz my headache not
like cold like cuz my hair gets wet when
I sweat and then it's just like freezing
on my head and then it just gives me a
headache
I like everything called we had this one
training evolution in the Marine Corps
one time it's back in Camp Pendleton and
I think it was like probably like under
10 degrees so we had like this 8 mile
hike somewhere and then we're all
drenched right and by the time we get
there we make a camp it's like nighttime
and it's really cool but you're also
really really wet cuz you just hiked
eight miles you're drenched like a
[ __ ] so I take up my I take off
my shirt I take off my they call it a
blouse I put on the side and I try to
let it air dry so I can go to sleep so I
go my sleeping bag naked and then when I
wake up I pick up my shirt and it's just
completely frozen it's completely frozen
it's a piece of cardboard okay and like
when I put it on I thought it was so
tight I like that like I just feel you
like that yeah like even when I picked
up my helmet there's like little icicles
like where my my sweat kind of this way
down to went down like me frozen sweat
sweat one of the melt is all salty yeah
hey when you're in the shower if you
don't dry completely and then your shirt
sticks to you I don't like that hate my
cousin loves it he likes the shirt
[ __ ] stuff don't like being like a
little lay wet and then putting a shirt
on that's like sweatshirts cuz that
feels good but like regular shirts oh
you're like jeans oh well I don't know
what it's like to put on jeans anymore
but yeah I could imagine
I like to call makes me happy I know
this fool was pretty much naked when we
went to it was Mount Fuji oh yeah in
Japan though all the tours were looking
at you like you were a bear reincarnate
and [ __ ] they're like what the [ __ ] yeah
because when you see your breath in the
air holding a macho dude and he had his
like his uh sweater or jacket like like
wrapped around his waist and everyone
else is like covered up to like here
Bartz meant to be a Alaskan seal man
dude that's why your child constantly
sweats that floor just looks literally
like you dip them in oil by the window
and it's cold like it's colder now and
then I'll feel his little hands and he's
cold and I'm like we weren't you crying
but his body and it's hot and sweating
like dinner I look at him on my head
trust me I know how you feel daddy knows
man being able to generate like a lot of
body heat though that's kind of like
strong Chi so it's like a lot of energy
must have a ton of to thank there might
be a boy thing nobody but he still gets
super hot well when I was pregnant
Wallace I was a tiny ass kid I'd even
breakdown hundred pounds I was in high
school but she straight up though he has
like two superpowers unlimited heat and
I'm literally spit Tigers oh my goodness
all serve machine was a [ __ ] gonna turn
off dude when I was pregnant with him I
think the last couple months um I
started feeling that same heat that I
guess you would complain about and I
would get hotter than he would at times
and there's the time where we're eating
at a restaurant it was in the middle of
the summer they didn't have an a/c and I
just couldn't stop I couldn't I couldn't
finish my food because I'm like we have
to get out of here I'm gonna pass like
this is really really hot me why I'm
complaining about the yeah it's really
uncomfortable I feel bad for anyone that
feels extremely hot it's sucks yeah I'd
rather take us being cold and like need
like thinking I'm gonna die cuz I feel
so cold and Bing you just be like oh
yeah you can't run away from recalls a
million times over it I mean I know in
Taiwan like my shirt it looked like I
was a seventh grader yeah because if you
started drooping you know like that the
droopy centigrade
whereby ringneck is all big and there's
no people with scars yeah you guys are
crazy it was during the cold time of
Taiwan it was like 90 degrees a jacket
Taiwan at a hundred and twenty percent
humidity people think of about
Californians because like we complain
you know and it's like when it dips
below 70 were like Oh Ian's jacket yeah
it's very interesting in Taiwan I don't
want to say like I'm like hating on it
but they're like some of the worst
dressed people I ever seen in my life
what is that what is that about you know
like a fashion thing there are something
well it's I I think it's because of new
money Oh cuz it's a new country right so
I feel like countries have different
stages like the first stage is they need
stability so they just got out of like
the broke phase and now they need
stability and then they're once they
have that old money they're gonna get
into fashion yeah everything's made of
Taiwan though like they make it they're
like oh these people are wearing some
weird [ __ ]
or maybe the art fashion it's just not
our style you know we're away about this
they're in their own world blush colored
socks baby that's how I wasn't I was
living in Mexico like everyone has like
their own style at that time but then
like it was so different from when I was
used to when I was living here but then
I ended up starting like slowly morphing
into the likes of their style like I
wanted to get shoes that they had like
snakeskin boots like the ski boots with
the big curl he told ya know those came
out after I live there and I was like
that has to be a joke no one actually
like my shoes yeah they actually have
them like super curly that's crazy
damn
[Music]